Ask any movie fan to name a specific breed
of big screen adventure, and action is sure
to be among the first.
Providing audiences with memorable heroes
and grand escapism, action movies have entertained
moviegoers time and time again, establishing
too many beloved characters and franchises
to count.
But which ones stand out from the rest?
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 best action movies
ever made.
Raiders of the Lost Ark
George Lucas and Steven Spielberg teamed up
to deliver a thrilling homage to film serials
of the ’30s and ’40s with this sweeping
adventure.
Harrison Ford was perfectly cast as the lead,
injecting Indiana Jones with the same charm
and roguish attitude that made Han Solo a
fan-favorite.
The action sequences were brilliantly crafted,
as everything from Ford’s truck stunt to
the airplane fight made good on the film’s
tagline of hailing the return of “the great
adventure.”
It also didn’t hurt that the villains Indy
faced were tenacious and terrifying.
More than deserving of its Best Picture nomination,
Raiders is the definition of a timeless adventure
classic.
First Blood
Though the Rambo series is now known for over-the-top
action, the franchise was born from humble
beginnings.
In the first installment, John Rambo is simply
a Vietnam veteran trying to return to American
society when he is accused of being a troublesome
drifter by an abusive sheriff.
Scarred and traumatized from his time overseas,
Rambo snaps and enters a fight for his life.
Raw and authentic, First Blood features one
of Sylvester Stallone’s finest performances,
filled with deep psychological subtext as
well as action.
The film also raised serious questions about
how we treat our war veterans, giving it strong
substance to go with the spectacle.
Lethal Weapon
One of the films that helped create the modern
buddy-cop subgenre, Lethal Weapon is one of
the most elite examples ever offered.
A lion’s share of the credit goes to the
irresistible pairing of Mel Gibson and Danny
Glover, whose chemistry helped create one
of Hollywood’s greatest dynamic duos.
More than the action, this film’s key strength
is the characters, who were just as entertaining
to watch bickering as they were in a gunfight.
The mixture of Gibson’s loose cannon and
Glover’s by-the-books family man gave way
to a lasting friendship, rewarding audiences
with a heartwarming ending to a thrilling
ride.
Die Hard
Arguably the best example of an action movie
in its purest form, Die Hard still holds up
more than 25 years after its release.
The movie was noteworthy for painting John
McClane as a vulnerable action hero, and not
an invincible superhero.
Every hit the New York cop took drew blood,
and forced him to push through more adversity
– to the point where he – and the audience
– believed he wasn’t making it out alive.
We’d be crazy to not praise Hans Gruber,
one of the action genre’s most iconic villains,
never slipping out of control, and able to
inspire feari in nearly anyone.
Between great characters and standout set
pieces, Die Hard is required Holiday viewing.
Terminator 2: Judgment Day
James Cameron upped the ante considerably
with his sequel to The Terminator and didn’t
disappoint.
T2 was a watershed moment for the film industry,
pioneering CGI technology with the frightening
T-1000 and ushering in a new age of Hollywood
special effects.
The director proved he was at the top of his
craft by helming nail-biting action sequences
that constantly escalated from one scene to
the next.
The film also had a powerful narrative and
themes about fate and friendship, centering
on the young John Connor and the Terminator
sent back in time to protect him.
Even now, it’s hard not to shed a tear when
Arnold sacrifices himself with a final thumbs-up.
Point Break
Forget the remake: the original tale of Johnny
Utah is where it’s at.
Adrenaline filled and action packed, Point
Break introduced the masses to action star
Keanu Reeves and paired the laid back actor
with the charismatic Patrick Swayze to give
audiences a strong and complex relationship.
The FBI agent struggling to fit in while going
undercover gave the film an interesting and
uncommon angle, capitalizing on the audience’s
unwillingness to see Swayze as an unlikable
“villain.”
Aside from the thrilling sequences on land,
the ocean, and in the air, director Kathryn
Bigelow showed that a woman could deliver
testosterone-fueled drama as well as – or
better than – her male competitors.
Bad Boys
Michael Bay may divide fans these days, but
his career got off to a rousing start.
Combining a slick visual style with the energetic
coupling of Will Smith and Martin Lawrence,
Bad Boys instantly became one of the absolute
standout buddy cop flicks.
The chemistry between the two stars was entertaining
to watch, and Bay made it clear that few directors
had his eye for large-scale action.
Though the story didn’t reinvent the wheel,
it was still a blast to see it all unfold,
with unexpected comedy, unforgettable set
pieces, and a killer soundtrack.
Is it any wonder why people are begging for
a third instalment?
The Matrix
Equal parts creative and groundbreaking, the
Wachowskis gave a generation of moviegoers
one of their defining sci-fi films with this
tale of man vs. machine.
The directors raised the bar for visual effects,
introducing moviegoers to the awe-inspiring
possibilities of bullet time, allowing them
to break convention and deliver something
never before seen.
The movie also had great substance to go with
that style, giving Neo a great character arc
and rounding out the cast with talented actors
like Lawrence Fishburne and Hugo Weaving.
The Matrix inspired countless imitators, but
we never get tired of watching the pioneers
at their best.
The Bourne Ultimatum
One of the few franchises that got better
with each installment, Paul Greengrass and
Matt Damon exceeded all expectations with
this trilogy finale.
Further developing his mastery of the “shaky
cam” aesthetic, the filmmaker incorporated
real stunts into his techniques, giving us
tense fights that always hit home.
It also didn’t hurt that the talented cast
gave honest and compelling performances, with
David Strathairn proving a slimy and worthwhile
adversary for our hero.
Unpacking more about Bourne’s past also
gave this film some dramatic heft to compliment
the action.
Fans can’t wait to see Matt Damon return
to the role, and given his send-off, it’s
easy to see why.
The Raid: Redemption
In an age of CGI heavy tentpoles, The Raid
was a much-needed breath of fresh air.
Director Gareth Evans combined the sheer awesomeness
of the spotlighted Indonesian martial arts
style, and revolutionary camerawork that immersed
viewers into the fights, giving audiences
one of the best crafted action films in recent
memory.
Evans also ramped up the tension by blending
in elements of a survival horror film with
villains that rival some of Hollywood’s
most notorious evildoers.
Inventive, jaw dropping, and a sheer delight
to see on-screen The Raid transcends the genre
and is a must-see for any movie fan.
It’s just that good.
Those are our picks for the best action movies
ever made.
Do you agree with our list?
Which action flicks get your heart racing?
Sound off in the comments section below and
be sure to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one!